hey what's up my name's samuel leeds and
in this video i'm going to be answering
your property investment questions i've
been in property now for 12
years buying a lot of houses packaging
and selling deals i've done over 300
property investment deals
and in this video i'm going to be
answering your niggling questions
so what do i need you to do well the
first thing i need you to do is i need
you to smash the like button
also make sure you're subscribed to the
channel turn the notification bell on
once you've done that i want you to ask
your questions
any questions that you've got around
property around hmos
rent to rents uh anything at all what's
niggling you
comment below in the chat box and i will
do my very best to answer your question
next week let's see what we had last
week so we've had a whole bunch of
questions come in
some really really good questions too
and while i'm answering these questions
it might be that you get like an
offshoot of a question in which case
just go ahead and ask away
so b3 says as you mentioned in the
previous video the big companies and
banks are investigating in residential
property in the uk and planning to
become large landlord companies that is
correct
what's your outlook on small investors
will competition be harder due to the
big players probably changing rules etc
to benefit themselves
um i think listen the market's always
changing when a new big player comes in
things might change
however like john lewis for instance
they're coming in they're building
10 000 houses how's that going to affect
you as a small investor
well if anything it's going to bring
property prices down slightly
because the more houses that are built
it means that there's more of them
in which case it's going to you know you
can set all the markets slightly which
could be a good thing for you
if you're just getting into it you want
house prices to go down
um i remember when they brought in
section 24
and they said however it doesn't apply
to companies
but then they changed the rules slightly
and said that you can set up a virgin
company and be a guarantor on that
company
like you you i think the market is so
vast you just need to be fluid and as
prices go up a bit down a bit
rents go up a bit rents go down a bit
you just need to use
the right strategies at the right time
and as an entrepreneur the definition of
an entrepreneur is somebody that's just
finding ways to add value make money
so my strategies that i'm doing now are
different than what i was doing
five years ago different to what i was
doing 10 years ago so
i wouldn't worry about the market
changing because all these big players
are coming in because in fact if big
players come in it's probably going to
open opportunities you just need to know
how to look for them
so i'm never worried about competition
um i hope that helps
next question is enki blogs who says i
viewed a property in sunderland which
turned out to be in a really rough area
so bad that i almost got murdered
serious wow how do you regain the
confidence to view houses again after a
terrifying experience
thank you firstly i'm really sorry to
hear that you almost got murdered in
sunderland while viewing houses
that's dreadful i mean listen there's
good and bad
in every area so if you go to london
okay there's really really expensive
parts really nice parts then there's
really rough parts if you go to
birmingham same story
if you go to sunderland i'm sure there's
good parts of sunderland bad parts of
sunderland
um i wouldn't advise trying to buy a
house in an area that's so rough
that you feel unsafe because those types
of areas
you know you can tell that it's like
that if you feel unsafe drive there at
night and if there's
you know um if you just feel unsafe
getting out the car if there's sofas all
outside the houses there's
boarded up windows maybe you can you
sense that it's um you know there's
working girls there and it just feels a
bit
then that kind of area is going to
attract
the total wrong kind of tenants however
if you go to a really luxurious area
like a really high sought after area
probably chances are that it's going to
be really expensive to get in those
areas
and the more expensive the house is
doesn't it doesn't necessarily mean that
the rent is also more expensive and the
return on investment might be lower
so my favorite type to area to invest is
um if the place where you almost got
murdered if that's like a one out of ten
in terms of how terrible it is and a 10
out of 10
is somewhere you know really really
really posh like mayfair london
i like to look at areas that are like
three four
so they're just a little below average a
little you know needed maybe maybe
they're getting regenerated a little bit
but they're not terrible
um but i'm really sorry to hear about
your experience i would just say maybe
try and find slightly safer areas hope
that helps
okay um steve says is 50k
really enough to begin a buy to let
portfolio
um steve it's definitely enough to begin
yes if you've got 50k
um that's easily enough to buy a house
to rent out
i mean normally you're going to be able
to get a 75
mortgage so if you found a 100 000 pound
house
you'd need 25 000 pounds plus stamp duty
maybe just um legal fees mortgage
mortgage um mortgage broker fee you're
probably talking about 35
000 pounds so if you've got 50 grand you
can definitely start your buy today
portfolio
my advice would probably be to learn how
to use that 50 000 pounds to buy a house
push the value up and then get the money
back so you can recycle it but
that's 100 enough to get started jason
allen
hi samuel love your videos thanks for
all the content you provide what are
your thoughts on investing in a hmo
and letting to a social housing
guaranteeing you a rental income for a
few years
jason i think it's a great idea um if
you're buying a hmo property you can
rent that out to students you can rent
that to professionals you can rent that
out to dss
tenants you can rent that out to a on a
corporate let you can rent it out to
a housing association ultimately when
you've got a property that you've broken
it up
room by room you're going to fetch more
rent and there's massive advantages to
doing a social housing
because number one you're helping often
helping the homeless or helping a good
cause
number two you're getting a guaranteed
rent
and number three there's no hassle
maintenance voids so
that is something that i've done with
many of my hmos and i think it's a good
strategy as long as you choose the right
housing association okay haki says can
you make a video
on how to avoid property tax as much as
possible
um yeah i certainly can if i had to give
you the top three ways to avoid property
tax right now i would say number one
um if you want to avoid stamp duty buy
properties that
are in a really bad condition that are
unhabitable
and you won't pay stamp duty or get
multiple dwelling relief or buy
properties
less than 40 000 pounds those are some
ways to avoid stamps due to
second way to avoid tax is buy a
property through a company
and you'll be able to claim the mortgage
payments uh
back as tax deductible the interest on
the debt you'll pay back is tax
deductible there's a second tip
top three how to avoid tax is make sure
that you keep
all of your expenses so anything that
you are spending
whether it be petrol um whether it be um
you know buying gifts for tenants
anything at all buying flowers for the
estate agents everything that you spend
that's going towards your business keep
the receipts and ask your accountant if
you can claim that back
as tax deductible so there are a few
tips off the top of my head
okay nathan newbury after thinking about
your video in which the builder messed
you around my question is for this week
what are the tips for self
managing a project when starting out and
the relationship rapport
is new between us and our build team
so if you're going to be managing a
build team and
you're going to be managing it yourself
what i would say is my biggest top tip
would be
make sure that you're the build team
that you're working with give you a
schedule of works
what that means is it means right week
one we're gonna be doing this
week two we're gonna be doing this it
might be week one we're gonna do the rip
out
rip everything out week two we're gonna
do the um the first fixes so the
electricians and the plumbers are gonna
come to the first fix
week three we're gonna um you know start
doing the plastering week four
and you just have a schedule of works
and then that way
every week you can check to see if your
builders on track
also make sure that the quote that the
builder gives you is broken down and
itemized so the builder's not saying
oh to refurb this house it's going to be
20 grand because that's no good
because what does that actually include
the builder needs to say
to refurb this house here's the itemized
quote
the plastering is going to be five grand
the new kitchen is gonna be five grand
the decorating is gonna be two grand the
carpets are gonna be too grand because
otherwise
it can cause arguments because the
builder might go out and finish now and
you go hang on a minute where the
carpets the bottle says
no i'm not carpeting it that's i didn't
mean i didn't i didn't include that when
i said refurb
oh why is it not painted oh that's a
decorator's job i'm a builder
so you need to be really clear on the
itemization of works and the schedule of
works
um and also find builders that you um
have got good reviews they may become
recommended
and make sure that you're on them you
know have a whatsapp group make sure
that you're regularly visiting seeing
what the build is doing that's my
advice okay maybe one or two more
questions i hope you enjoyed the video
if you are smash like and don't forget
to comment your questions below
as well so i can answer your questions
too okay miles some phone how fast can
you change rent to serviced
accommodation from c3 to c1
due to the 90 day rule in london um
miles i'd probably say
don't bother because to change it from a
c3 to a c1
you're gonna have to get planning
permission if this is a rent-to-service
accommodation that means you don't own
the property
i personally wouldn't go through the
aggro of getting planning permission on
a house that i did not own
unless i had an option on it maybe try
and get the rent to rent into a
lease option and then it's a whole
different story okay last question
bro bro what's the best way to get
property deals for buy refurbished
finance do you think yorkshire is
tough to get these deals um listen
getting borrowed february finance deals
um is it tough yeah of course it's tough
you can't just
walk into an estate agent and say i want
a br deal please can you give me one and
they'll give you a perfect
put your money in pull your money out
deal you need to find properties that
have got
problems where are you going to find
these maybe you could find them at
auction
an auction that's got a property with
japanese knotweed a property that can't
sell because it's got structural
problems
you need to find problem properties with
motivated sellers
and then you want to work out can you
fix that problem
if you can't fix the problem it's no
good but you want to get good at
fixing property problems find the find
the worst
um the worst house in the street turn it
to the best house in the street
if it's got um structural problems work
out
how much is it going to cost for you to
fix that problem and ultimately how much
is that going to
lift the property by and every time you
spend a pound on fixing a problem
it needs to add three pounds to the
value of the house that's a good rule of
thumb
where do you find these deals you can
find them from estate agents
i found a really good way to find them
as well is pre and post auctions
and also tell the world that you're a
property investor
tell the world what you do and when you
speak it out and you say what you're
looking for
and you tell the world suddenly things
start coming your way
so i hope you guys found this video
helpful and i look forward to seeing you
next time if you want to see more videos
like this you can check out a whole
playlist up here
comment below ask me your questions
subscribe and i look forward to seeing
you guys
next time